can actually speak our mind so because  even historically how can we say we were  oppressed and we didn't have to fight in  wars but i think we yeah we may we may  not have physically have to fight in  wars i think you know at the end of the  day men do have more physical strength  than women that's a fact there's no  doubt about that and i think because of  that it's created so certain dynamics so  for example you know when what you said  about security we know we associate  security with physical security you know  physical safety you know if if if we're  being attacked by something it's it's  our physical strength that is going to  protect us from it if we're going to eat  then it's the physical physical act of  eating that's going to protect us from  it so we've always just from that  natural instinct we've always kind of  had that superiority of physical traits  being superior because it's  superior benefits in our survival as  human beings